bonjour et bienvenue dans les 4V Marc on
est un peu perdu là face à la colère des
agriculteurs ce matin les blocages qui
persistent en plusieurs endroits dans le
pays les appels de certains agriculteurs
à bloqué des villes comme Lyon ou Paris
c'est une queue de comète ou ça veut
dire que le problème reste entier on
continue à travailler avec leurs
représentants pour continuer le Premier
ministre a dit vendredi et annoncer un
certain nombre de mesures il a dit
qu'elle suivrait d'autres mesures donc
mes on continue à travailler avec eux
pour proposer dans la simplification not
et puis on va voir une semaine
européenne on en dira peut-être un mot
proposer un certain nombre de mesures
qui viendront attester la volonté du
gouvernement à la fois de sortir de la
crise mais surtout d'apporter des r
c'est demain les nouvelles mesures c'est
dans dans les 48 heur on aura un certain
nombre de choses qu'on pourra poser sur
la table qui permettront je crois de de
compléter et de montrer la globalité des
mesures qu'on entend proposer agricole
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la crise au
momentù SE par la crise n'est pas
derrière nous la crise agricole n'est
pas derrière nous vous voyez bien que la
crise telle qu'elle s'est exprimée elle
est multiple il y avait des crises sur
les questions fiscales il y a des crises
sur la question de la simplification et
la simplification il faut prendre le
temps de regarder ce qu'on peut
simplifier déjà et puis on a des sujets
européens il y aura un Conseil européen
le président de la République a souhaité
mettre ce point à l'ordre du jour jeudi
prochain je serai moi-même à Bruxelles
dans la semaine pour avancer sur des
sujets je pense au sujet viticol et à
d'autres sujets je pense au sujet jacher
on a vu on va en parler de la la jacher
tout à l'heure on a vu la mobilisation
policière et les gendarmes très
impressionnantes notamment pour protéger
le marché de marché de ringis
aujourd'hui si les les les agriculteurs
décident de contrôler les camions aux
entrées de Paris de vérifier leur
contenu la proven des produits est-ce
que vous les laisserez faire l'idée
c'est de là où il y a des manifestations
et c'est d'ailleurs j'ai entendu les
responsables nationaux des syndicats le
dire et qu'il souhaitait faire les
choses en bon ordre et en respectant les
biens et les personnes dès lors qu'on
respecte les biens et les personnes pas
de difficulté majeur contrôler contrôler
les contenus
des me semble-til c'est le rôle des
douanes c'est le rôle des services et
d'ailleurs il comp ils vont accentuer un
certain nombre de
contrôles au niveau national parce que
c'est important de vérifier que la
provenance c'est pas seulement la
provenance c'est par rapport à
l'étiquetage
ch en tout cas c'est pas aux
agriculteurs de le faire euxmême c'est
c'est le travail continue du
gouvernement et c'est le travail Contin
continu de nos administrations de
vérifier la nature des produits qui
rentrent sur le sol français on en est
où dans le dans le rapport entre ces
agriculteurs et les forces de l'ORD
participé hier soir à une cellule
interministérielle présidé par par
Gérald daranin on a l'impression que le
la ligne a changé on n plus tout à fait
dans allez-y messieur dames on vous
comprend la police n'interviendra pas le
le ministre de l'Intérieur effectivement
on a tenu une réunion hier il a il a dit
deux choses
un que les manifestants puissent
exprimer ce qu'il av av été exprimé de
leur colère et de leur revendication
deuxième élément qu'on ne pouvait pas
rentrer dans une logique qui consistera
à bloquer Paris ou les grandes
métropoles régionales et puis des points
stratégiqu que sont les aéroports
ringissent au niveau d'ailleurs
franilien comme au niveau régional c'est
la ligne qui est qui est celle affirmée
par le gouvernement c'est une ligne de
bon sens mais je répète j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'esprit de responsabilité chez
les responsables syndicaux pour faire en
sorte que ça se fasse en bon ordre et
sans des nuisances qui seraient
paronsous franchement Marc est-ce que
vous avez peur que ça dérape est-ce que
le risque de dérapage est plus important
en ce début de semaine tendue que la
semaine dernière quand on pensait que ça
allait s'arranger moi je vais vous dire
quand vous êtes responsable politique
vous devez toujours faire attention au
mots et à ce que vous dites parce que
l'esprit de responsabilité il doit pas
attiser la colère il doit plutôt essayer
de l'apaiser donc il y a pas une
question d'avoir peur ou pas peur en
tout cas dans nos des degrés
d'inquiétude et les français
s'inquiètent aussi se POS des questions
je comprends que les français
s'inquiètent ou que certains
s'inquiètent en tout cas nous moi
j'essaie de travailler à faire en sorte
de répondre aux injonctions et aux
demandes des agriculteurs et en fait et
le faire aussi avec les mots qui soient
juste et qui sonnent juste on est
d'accord que des chars enfin des des des
des blindés devant Rist des blindé c'est
pas fréquent quand même non mais ça peut
arriver dans des mouvements où il peut y
avoir des véhicules lourds parce que
c'est des véhicules lourds qui sont
annoncés par certains plutôt marginaux
de la contestation et c'est normal qu'on
mette des véhicules lourds face à des
véhicules lourds Marc fé il y a quelque
chose qu'on comprend pas c'est le fameux
deux po de mesure qu'on dont on entend
beaucoup parler depuis quelques jours
quand des adistes bloquent une parcelle
d'autoroute ça a été le cas sur la 69
entre tounous et Tarne en octobre
dernier ça a été démelés en 24 heures
ils sont délogés par les forces de l're
et en fait les forces de l' et tout le
monde trouve ça normal pourquoi avec les
agriculteurs vous marchez sur les sur
sur des ufs à ce point-l pourquoi il y a
pas de PO de mesure dès qu'il y a eu des
actes de violence attendez dès qu'il y a
eu des actes de violence ils ont été
condamnés dès qu'il y a eu des actes de
violence il a des procédures qui sont en
cours ouais en même temps vous avez
voyez bien la colère et la désespérance
qui s'exprime dans le monde agricole ça
justifie le trouble à l'ordre public ou
pas il y a le trouord public ne se
justifie jamais mais des manifest pardon
mais quand on bloque une autoroute
est-ce qu'il y a pas un trouble d'ordre
public est-ce qu'il y a pas un
empêchement d'aller travailler il s'agit
pas mon les uns contre les autres mais
juste de comprendre non mais l'idée j'ai
bien compris c'était pas l'objectif de
votre de votre question mais l'obj c'est
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse rentrer
dans le dialogue avec les agriculteurs
de respecter leurs mouvement et leurs
revendications et de le faire sans qu'il
puisse y avoir recours à la violence et
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
ça le le sujet principal vous dites
qu'il y aura d'autres mesures qui seront
annoncées sans doute dans dans les 48
heur je vrais qu'on on réexplique si
c'est possible de manière simple rapide
et pas trop technique quelquesunes des
mesures qui sont pas suffisamment
claires sans doute est-ce que vous
pouvez déjà nous réexpliquer très
simplement le dispositif du GNR parce
que je suis peut-être un peu couillon
mais moi j'ai pas compris à partir de
quand combien ça va leur faire
économiser sur le GNR le pétrole non
dès à présent l'augmentation ne
s'appliquera plus aura pas
l'augmentation il y aura pas
l'augmentation deuxième élément on va
faire une avance de trésorerie parce que
c'est une avance que c'est une taxe que
vous payez qu'on vous remboursez donc
ils n'uront plus à l'avancer on va dès à
présent dès le mois de février le leur
payer 50 % de ce qu'ils auraient eu
comme remboursement et à partir du 1er
juillet c'est une mesure de
simplification ça sera directement
déduit de la facture d'accord donc ça
c'est clair les agriculteur V fin avec
la jachè obligé d'une partie de leur
terre c'est une décision au niveau
européen que vous évoquez ça sera fin
quand la j les 4 % de jcher imposé alors
c'est une mesure effectivement au niveau
européen qui est mal comprise quand on
importe 40 millions de tonnes de
céréales et donc c'est une mesure on y
travail c'est pas tout à fait nouveau
qu'on y travaille j'ai pris la la le lad
si vous me permettez cette expression
d'une coalition de pays européens nous
sommes 22 pays européens à
demander cette obligation de J cher soit
levée pourquoi parce que par je vous
arrête de secondes comment c'est
possible que sur 27 pays 22 pays
demandent cette obligation soit levée et
qu'elle ne soit pas levée mais parce
qu'on a besoin pardon de vous le dire
que la Commission européenne quand il y
a une expression et je pense que c'est
un des débats qu'on ira dans le débat
qu'on aura dans le débat européen quand
on autant de pays disent des choses il
faut que il y ait un processus plus
rapide même s'il peut y avoir des sujets
juridiques je peux l'entendre un
processus plus rapide de décision
d'ailleurs on a eu le même sujet sur les
questions ukrainiennes ou parfois la
lenteur de décision fait que la colère
monte ou l'impatience grandit et on a
besoin d'e commission vous souhaitez
vous souhaitez que ce soit pour quand la
je souhaite que dans la semaine pour la
campagne qui va s'ouvrir évidemment de
culture enfin elle est déjà ouverte à
vrai dire la décision puisse être prise
dans la semaine il faut que la décision
soit prise l'objectif que nous assignons
j'y vais pour ça et le président de la
République appuiera toutes ses forces
sur ce sujet vous évoquez l'Ukraine pour
soutenir l'effort de guerre en Ukraine
on a accordé aux Ukrainiens des règles
d'exportation très favorabl dont l'effet
pervers et qu'elles affaiblissent nos
propres agriculteurs nos propres
éleveurs allez-vous revenir sur ces
facilité et quand oui il y a des effets
pervers sur les marchés au démarrage ça
avait peu de d'effets déstabilisateurs
c'est une mesure effectivement de
soutien à l'Ukraine et nous serons au
rendez-vous du soutien l'Ukraine
simplement la déstabilisation du marchés
tel que nous devons prendre des mesures
donc nous travaillons et ça sera l'objet
aussi des discussions qu'il y aura cette
semaine à faire en sorte que il y ait
une limite à ces importationss limiteou
une suppression de ces aides on verra en
tout cas que vous souhaitez vous en tant
que ministre de l'agricult moi je
souhaite en tant que ministre de
l'Agriculture que dès lors que ça vient
désorganiser les marchés on puisse y
mettre un terme donc après il faut
trouver les vois et moyens soit sur les
volumes soit sur les montant peu importe
le sujet et ça concerne quoi ça concerne
la volaille ça concerne les œufs ça
concerne le sucre vous souhaitez les
avantages sur la volaille les œufs et le
sucre pour dès lors qu'il vient produire
dès lors qu'il vientnent produire une
désorganisation de marché on doit on
doit demander j'ai été en ucraine il y a
quelques mois pour dire cela en disant
un moment quand vous créez autant de
tension sur les marchés vous vous nous
jouons collectivement contre les
intérêts de l'Ukraine et donc les
Ukrainiens qui entendent aussi cette
difficulté je suis sûr qu'ils
comprendront la mesure qui va
s'organiser au niveau européen donc
là-dessus c'est clair le président de de
LR eric cioti a une proposition il
demande la DISP la mise en place d'un
dispositif d'accompagnement financier
aucun agriculteur dit-il ne doit gagner
moins de 1500 € net par mois est-ce que
c'est sur la table une sorte de revenu
minimum pour les agriculteurs je trouve
très curieuse cette cette proposition
position d'abord je sais pas comment il
a d'ailleurs quand vous quand il est
interrogé il est oui il est inf fichu de
de dire comment il le fait il propose
juste de prendre à l'urbain pour faire
le rural c'estàd qu'on vient réorganiser
une querelle entre l'urbain et le rural
je ne comprends pas comment il finance
cette mesure pour que les agriculteurs
touche 1500 € ou plus la question c'est
la question de la rémunération et du
revenu c'est pour ça qu'on travaille sur
des mesures qui viendront s'assurer que
égalim la loi qui visait à faire en
sorte que la matière première agricole
soit payée parce que décréter c'est très
bureaucratique ce que propose monsieur
sioti il propose un salaire minimum et
les agriculteurs ils ont pas envie d'un
salaire
minimum non mais mais les agriculteurs
moi ce que j'entend sur le terrain c'est
qu'ils ont envie de non pas de prime ou
d'ind à la subsistance ils ont envie de
revenus ils ont envie de rémunération et
donc je pense que Monsieur sooti devrait
suivre avec nous plutôt le chemin de la
rémunération de leurs produits sinon
vous allez attester que les produits
peuvent être bas et que l'État viendrait
compenser une perte de revenus c'est pas
ça la logique économique bon mais quand
même Marc F on a l'impression qu'il y a
plus de il y a plus de problème
environnmentaux que ça compte plus
depuis une dizaine de jours il y a qu'un
jour on allait tous mourir des
pesticides je caricature un peu
aujourd'hui c'est toujours si on ne dit
pas prenez-en un verre à laapéro enfin
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est non c'est
pardon c'est vous caricaturez un petit
peu beaucoup peut-être sur le sujet la
volonté qu'on a sur ces questions de
simplification c'est c'est de faire en
sorte que dans la trajectoire que nous
avons choisi on ne vienent pas envoyer
des injonctions contradictoire et
deuxième élément pardon nous vivons dans
un espace qui est l'espace européen donc
se faire ces petites règles à soi comme
même si on vivait sur une île déserte
quand l'Espagne l'Italie l'Allemagne eux
aussi se souci de sensé publi et
d'environnement font leur propres règles
il y a quelque chose qui dfonctionne
donc on a besoin d'avoir des règles
européennes première chose de tenir des
trajectoires mais de le tenir avec une
forme de cohérence et de simplification
on sent que le problème est largement
européen ce matin dernière question
rapidement vous êtes aussi un
parlementaire un député Marc fenau dans
le climat social actuel comment vous
avez accueilli la décision des députés
de s'accorder un peu plus de 300 € de
frais supplémentaire par mois euh c'est
la responsabilité du bureau de
l'Assemblée pour bien connaître les
choses je comprends que ça été vécu
comme une mesure mal à drroite cétait
mal venu c'éta pas le moment je je
comprends tout est important dans ma
phrase je comprends que dans l'opinion
publique c'est été ch posé chez vous
hein mais oui mais on ESS j'essaie de
dire les choses avec sincérité et de
dire de façon pesée parce que je
pense je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
rompu à l'exercice des éléments de
langage je le dis avec mes mots et je le
dis de façon pesée et donc c'est la
prérogative de l'Assemblée nationale ça
a été vécu comme quelque chose de
maladroit il y a la mesure et il y a le
moment de la mesure manifestement le
moment de la mesure était mal choisi
merci beaucoup Marc F de donner 4V bonne
journée à vous